la carie lagos où va dire au revoir à
jean luc lemoine parce qu'il part au
théâtre i way saison en fait cela pour
les cinq ans vraiment merci pour tout ce
que vous avez fait en cinq ans et puis
rendez les mois bien
[Musique]
verdict ce soir c'est ça alors la cabine
soit bien parti j'attends qu'il soit
bien parti
s'ils croient qu'on va l'épargné pendant
le prime cela le prépare un petit truc
vous inquiétez pas mon djamel alors
c'est très simple derrière il ya quelque
chose à aller voir quelque chose jamais
il faut vraiment le voir caché et vous
allez décrire ce que vous voyez moi
aussi je vais décrire ce que je vois et
vont essayer de dire qu'il pleuve ou
vous ou moi d'accord voilà je vais
regarder alors ah oui d'accord
ah ouais regarder le premier au nom de
dieu
incroyable mais vrai alors vous allez
dire ce que vous voyez et moi je vais
dire après ce que je vois à temps est ce
le sera bien aussi à décrire c'est un
truc de fou
un âne déguisé en zorro avec une cape de
zorro achats sombrero de zorro tous deux
euros mais c'est un mal le mec à la
place à à un homme déguisé en zorro vois
je vous dire ce que j'ai vu j'ai vu
rocco siffredi avec une béquille en dr
house avec avec quoi il avec une
béquille comme ça avant dr house il est
déguisé en doctors
alors toi tu dis la vérité moi qu'on
avait dit moi je montre tout non
alors vous dites que je bluffe vous
pensez que d'aucuns n'ont jamais le
bluff ciric bluff jamais là quand même
que leur clôture
je suis frais dire congo siffredi peu
plus il peut plus marcher
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il n'a pas voulu la faire mais alors
régime bien sûr vous dites la vérité
rocco siffredi pourquoi vous dites à vos
yeux vos yeux sont lumineux vous dites à
un bloc mais je bluffe lui dit la vérité
total indique ça toi j'ai confiance en
djamen ah oui on voit pas du tout ça
fait cinq ans qu'on est ensemble n'a pas
confiance en moi bah bravo à des
bâchages une demi heure annan déguisé en
zorro qu'une cape de zorro ouais mais un
masque de zorro botte droite est une
comme rocco siffredi mais moi je crois
que c'est là donc c'est vous qui me le
fais
cette donne
[Musique]
c'est qui cette dame s'écrie tué
personne c'est maintenant ma tante mais
on est d'habitude vient pas bonjour
madame
et enfin valérie bénaïm trois ans vous
cyril quoi c'est vrai moi je prends mes
pensées vont vers mayotte cette attente
alors djamel pour cette première cabine
le public sait qu'ils bluffent djabel
qui peuvent que c'est jamel je pense
toujours que je bosse hôpital à moi vous
me croyez ben c'est bien première fois
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
à 3-2 à la baleine
bien sûr les vallées bonne école devient
soro vient n'ai pas peur voilà merci
beaucoup
comment s'appellent ces fripons chic
répond un fripon comment ça va bien
belgique comment ça va mon frère ya de
ça un mal ça c'est un homme salue beau
il est beau moyen montée sur la il peut
monter sur la nouvelle z sur art est à
dire est que je vais je veux que je te
jette sur un fin spécialiste des hans et
vous ne touchez pas
[Rires]
cette phase i
secteur bourgade
merci frérot tembo cautionne
il est content avec nous m et parce que
c'est que ce peu la reine un beau plat
cette 7e mais c'est vrai ce galbe les
anneaux blake il faut 1 m merci
attention donc et vous avez été vous
regardez été bon on va faire ou pas on
va remplir jamais de l'arrière 1 à la
syrie
c'est comme gilles verdez jamais devant
lui hassan diab elle est trop bien
allez-y faites vos trucs on va faire la
deuxième cabine parce qu'on va la
remplir là on va la remplir 1 la
deuxième cabine jamel est a quand même
un âne déguisé en zorro fallait y aller
l'association gamal al rocco siffredi la
manière mais oui bien sûr car il ya une
deuxième cabine connaît lui connaît je
voudrais vous dire ce que je veux
prendre mon dieu c'est magnifique
moi j'ai jusqu'au début j'ai vu guy
lagache
impossible c'est incroyable quand même
guy lagache ans vivent ces gens
attendent et je voulais vous parler une
seconde parce qu'il faut qu'on
s'organise on verra les ifp et en débat
la mer dans les poubelles tétouan ont
été méchants c'est incroyable
orange aussi incroyable et à roselyne
bachelot qui fait des merguez
[Applaudissements]
ouais au classement du mariage alors
perez halal
c'est pas possible annonce va vous
suffit alors on dit quoi je veux que tu
bosses tu fais des blagues et halal
j'avais passé qui brille mais non il
engage son slip c'est que je veuille
trois exils a gâché lui qu'est ce que je
te disais c indique ce domaine au sein
duquel sa démission roselyne cuisine pas
je pense que la gâchette veut nous
montrer son sein les étranges visites
moi je fais confiance à jamel est c'est
quoi il commence à me faire chier si on
fait autant confiance à ce jour là elle
travaille avec lui c'est moi je t'engage
quand tu veux alors isabelle non les
merguez ça sentirait vu moi j'ai envie
de voir guy lagache en caleçon donc 10
et jamel qui bluffe allait révéler trop
réfléchi jamel c'est vous qui avez
raison
oh je vous avais moi j'ai trop réfléchi
de jane eyre c'est vous qui avez raison
mais j'aime bien on est ce que vous
savez que dit tout j'appelle ici et une
fois qu'on vous donnera la réponse je
vous dirai pourquoi jamel c'est que sa
réflexion fait des merguez à la radio
publique vous pensez est-ce que jamel
bluff qui disent bluff c'est qu'il vit
que je bluffe ice au plus jamel il pense
que jamais la raison et pour le futur
mais il faut ce que j'ai raison très
attention jamel
on m'a tiré le rideau dette / 7 /
attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout marché
on va faire ça c'est des merguez halal
pic idiote qui ne veulent pas accueillir
les magasins k6 30 mais il tenait
d'ailleurs un rossi donnait on vous lit
où vous les offre halal alors ces
importantes jamais ce que je peux tour à
côté
oui moi je vous avais dit que jamais la
visite et je vais vous dire pourquoi il
a hésité parce que on est allé derrière
la cabine
c'est à dire la vérité je ne lui jette
pas vu j'avais mal joué j'ai mal lu
roselyne ma part j'ai mal comment la
masse
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas vrai jeudi 12 euros non c'est
un bras et tous vos albums tu sois fier
dans les prés
le risque d'une étude à soitec de la
merde j'ai tout télécharger les films on
est allé derrière il m'a dit c'est quoi
la marque des merguez fiche est mal vu
la taille a une troisième qualité
demandait ce qu'elle était halal
oui c'est vrai le cardinal est prête
alors là je vais vous dire on va voir ce
qu'il ya comment est-ce que moi c'est là
que tu fais cette émission ça que voir
comment vous allez pouvoir s'est passé
là van damme et ces voix là on est là on
est au zénith on est là c'est vrai sur
le kilimandjaro
la villa garden au sommet du
kilimandjaro n'aura pas trouvé mais rien
à faire
la jeune fille a eu cette idée
extraordinaire donc je veux dire c'est
florent sebaoun la productrice
d'émissions voilà françois situe l'usiné
les autres fleurs magnifiques un moment
de grâce alors c'est magnifique ça se
trouvera je vais vous dire je vais vous
dire ce qu'on a ce qu'on a je vais vous
le dire
attention attention on a vu on a eu ou
pas il faut vraiment pas voir un gamin
tu dis nous tout ce que tu veux que tu
me suis le roi tu veux je dis d'abord
moi dis toi ouais ouais
ni toi parce que parce que moi ils vont
pas me croire forcément non c'est
franchement c'est l'heure du front on a
l rico macias déguisé en tintin ou froid
c'est magnifique voix la cc on peut pas
que tu aller plus haut on a moi je vais
vous dire la vérité
on à monsieur propre dans la cabine le
vrai monsieur propre à tête de verre le
seul l'unique le véritable monsieur
propre mesdames messieurs celui qu'on a
jamais vu on a toujours vu monsieur
propre sur les souris et la lie en chair
et en os et de ricoh et ea qu'ils ont
pensé pour faire monsieur propre
acquérez ara aprikian pas trop de débit
non alors ça s'appelle une private joke
parce que la plupart des gens si le
collège c'est le collège quand même un
hibou et voit la tête qu il s est enfui
sans cédric aux mafias sont atteints
mais voilà ça peut être le boss il
échoue en cèdre est comme assia son
tintin pour moi alors à votre avis qui
bout parce que là c'est pas fréquent de
se propres
ils sont ravis de la mer ça marche je
croyais vraiment que le grand pas compte
des huit chinois il s'est même pas des
mutilés pas trop de deux de canal et
tout serait tellement beau mais en
monsieur propre
ah oui papa c'est tout ce que je peux
vous le connaissez le patron je sais je
sais que c'est un haricot alors que je
peux pas tout mettre à vous donner la
réponse
[Applaudissements]
je sais que ce n est qu à la luis
enrique wada nickel je sais même pas si
je suis là ni quel vieux regagnait
excusez-moi roselyne mais vous n'êtes
pas très savoir garder
[Applaudissements]
baptisé le by pass
voilà et c'est une bombe on pourra être
capture d'écran merci à mr car les corps
qu'on adversaires merci madame et ses
saveurs
le quattro le patro le patron le panneau
est la seule arme c'est le big boss
c'est exceptionnel ça va moins ça va
merci d'être là mais je suis content de
pouvoir me marre marre aussi
il faut qu'on vous libère très vite et
bien libellée tuner
[Applaudissements]
merci à vous accompagner
évidemment si jamais le bout ça tous les
jours votre adversaire ou d'innovation
et elle est allée tout sera encore ainsi
de 16 heures à 18 heures contre dans les
pieds dans le plat
oh là là là quelle émission quelle
émission quelle émission
[Musique]